[Musique]
arlette laguiller espère dépasser les 5%
comme en 95 et en 2002 ce serait une
façon pour elle de clore un parcours
politique long d'une trentaine d'années
serge cimino et marque doux en suivit la
candidate de lutte ouvrière lors de l'un
de ses récents meeting à lyon ce soir
elle sera à nantes
du passé elle fait table rase arlette
laguiller n'aime pas regarder dans le
rétroviseur elle fait campagne sans trou
se retourner sur les cinq précédentes
trente trois ans après son premier acte
présidentielle
eh bien oui je suis une femme et j'ose
me présenter comme candidate à la
présidence de cette république dob la
première fois je me suis présenté
première femme première travail et ce en
1974 je sortais de deux mois de grève
une grève assez dur mais finalement on a
gagné et bah pour moi cette campagne
c'était un peu la continuité de ce
combat là donc maintenant ça va être
l'un vers c'est à dire bien sûr je suis
en retraite je peux plus faire grève
mais c'est vrai que je vais continuer à
être une militante et à me battre pour
mes idées
candidate ou pas candidate ça c'est
autre chose ça n'a pas tellement
d'importance travailleuses travailleurs
camarades et amis à force de campagne
elle a transformé sa popularité en
succès dans les urnes en 95 et 2002 elle
dépasse par deux fois la barre des 5%
mais ce capital sympathie arlette
laguiller va devoir le transmettre et
parmi les successeurs possibles mises en
lumière dans ce parti où on cultive le
secret nathalie arthaud 37 ans porte
parole de lutte ouvrière dans la région
lyonnaise les à l'entendre rien n'est
fait à l'âge la compagne parce qu'on est
en meeting à lyon quant aux
présidentielles si dans cinq ans donc là
vraiment je crois qu'on a le temps de
voir tout ça donc c'est pas vraiment
d'actualité pour l'instant
arlette laguiller vivra ses derniers
instants de candidate trotskiste à la
présidentielle dimanche prochain quel
que soit son score mais avant une réelle
retraite médiatique elle restera porte
parole de son parti pour la campagne des
législatives
juste après la présidentielle les
travailleurs et les travailleuses n'ont
pas encore perdu leur porte-voix fétiche
de ces 35 dernières années
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]